The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Why don't
we get started?
So today we're going to talk
about comparative genomics.
And first, a brief review
of what we did last time.
So last time we talked
about global alignment
of protein sequences,
including the Needleman-Wunsch
and Smith-Waterman algorithms.
And we talked about gap
penalties a little bit
and started to introduce the
PAM series of matrices which
are well described in the text.
So what I wanted to
do is just briefly
go over what I started to
talk about at the end, about
Markov models of evolution.
Because they're relevant,
not only for the PAM series,
but also for some other
topics in the course.
A short unit on
molecular evolution
we're going to do today.
And then they also introduce
hidden Markov models
that will come up
later in the course.
So the example that we gave of
a Markov model was DNA sequence
evolution in successive
generations where
the observation here is that the
base at a particular position
at generation n+1 here depends
on the base at that generation
and the base at generation n.
But conditional on knowing
the base at generation n,
you don't learn
anything from knowing
what that base was
at generation n-1.
That's the essence of
the Markov properties.
So here's the formal
definition, as we saw before.
Any questions on this?
And I asked you to review
your conditional probability
if it was rusty, because
that's very relevant.
OK so in this example you might,
if you had a random variable x
that represented the genotype
at a particular locus,
let's say the
apolipoprotein locus,
and it had alleles
A and a, then you
might write something
like the probability
that Bart's genotype
is a homozygous given
his grandfather's genotype
and his dad's genotype
is equal to just the conditional
probability given his father's
genotype.
So those are the sorts
of things that you
can do with Markov chains
So when you're working
with Markov chains
matrices are extremely useful.
So another thing that will
be helpful in this part
of the course and then again
in Professor Fraenkel's
part, where he's
talking-- he'll use also
some ideas from
linear algebra-- is
to review your basics
of matrices and vector
multiplication.
OK so, if you now make a
model of molecular evolution
where sn is-- so s
is this variable that
represents a particular
base in the genome
and is the generation.
And then to describe
the evolution
of this base over
time, we're going
to imagine that its evolution
is described by a Markov chain.
And a Markov chain can be
described by, in this case, a 4
by 4 matrix, since there are
four possible nucleotides
at generation i, for example,
and four possible at generation
i plus one.
And you simply need
to specify what
the conditional probability
that the base will
be, of any possible base, at
the next generation, given what
it is at the current generation.
So here's the matrix up here.
And it describes, for
example, the probability
of going from a c to an a.
So then in general
you might know
that that base is a g
at the first generation.
But in general you
won't necessarily
know what base it is if
you're modeling events that
may happen in the future.
So the most general
way of describing
what's happening at
that base is a vector
of probabilities of the
four possible bases--
so qa, qc, qg, qt, with those
probabilities summing up to 1.
And so then it turns out
that with this notation
that the content of the
vector at generation n plus 1
is equal to simply the
vector at generation n
multiplied on the
right by the matrix,
just using the standard
vector matrix multiplication.
So for example,
if we have vectors
with four things in
them, and we have
a 4 by 4 matrix, then to get
this term here in this vector
you multiply-- you basically
take the dot product
of this vector times
this first column.
The vector times
the first column
will give you that entry.
And this times this
column will give you
that entry in the
vector, and so forth.
And you can see that the
way this makes sense,
the way the matrix is defined,
that first column tells you
the probability that you'll have
an a at the next generation,
conditional on each
of the four bases
at the previous generation.
And so you just multiply by
the probabilities of those four
bases times the appropriate
conditional probability here.
And those are all
the ways that you
can be an a
generation, n plus 1.
And so it's also true that if
you want to go further in time,
so from generation
n to generation n
plus k-- k is some integer--
then this just corresponds
to sequential multiplication
by the matrix k--
I'm sorry, by the matrix p.
So qn plus 1 equals q times p.
And then qn plus 2 will
equal q-- I'm sorry.
That's a really bad q,
but-- qn plus 1 times p,
which will equal q times p
squared, where p squared means
matrix multiplication, again
using the standard rules
of matrix multiplication
that you can look up.
So one of the things you
might think about here
is what happens
after a long time?
If you start from some vector
q-- for example, q is 0010.
That is, it's 100% chance of g.
What would happen if
you run this matrix
on that over a long
period of time.
And we'll come back to that
question a little bit later.
So thinking about the
Dayhoff matrices-- and again,
I'm not going to go
into detail here,
because it's well
described in the text.
Dayhoff looked at these highly
identical alignments, these 85%
identical alignments, and
calculated the mutability
of each residue and these
mutation probabilities
for how often each residue
changes into each other one
and then scaled them so that on
average the chance of mutating
is 1% and then took
these probabilities,
these frequencies,
of mutation m, a, b,
divided by the frequency of
the residue b, took the log,
and then just multiplied by
two just for scaling purposes,
and came up with a-- and then
rounded to the nearest integer,
again for practical purposes.
And that's how she came
up with her PAM 1 matrix.
And then you can use
matrix multiplication
to derive all the
successive PAM series.
Just multiply the PAM1 matrix
times itself to get the PAM2
and recalculate the scores.
So if you actually use
PAM matrices in practice
there are some issues.
And these are also well
described in the text.
And the fundamental
problem seems
to be that the way the
proteins evolve over
short periods of time and
the way they evolve over
long periods of time
is somewhat different.
And basically this model, this
Markov model of evolution,
is not quite right, that things
don't-- what you see in a short
periods of time-- it does not
match long periods of time.
And why is that?
A number of possible reasons.
But keep in mind that
in addition to proteins
simply changing their
amino acid sequence,
other things can
happen in evolution.
You can have insertions
and deletions
that are not captured
by this Markov model.
And you can also have birth
and death of proteins.
A protein can evolve according
to this model for millions
of years.
And then it can become unneeded,
and just be lost, for example.
So real protein evolution
is more complicated.
And so about 20 years ago
or so Henikoff and Henikoff
decided to develop a
new type of matrix.
And the way they did it was
to identify these things
called blocks, which are regions
of reasonably high similarity,
but not as high as
Dayhoff required.
So there were many more--
Dayhoff was working the '70s.
They were working in the '90s.
So there were many more
proteins available.
And they could identify,
with confidence, basically
a much larger data
set, including
more distantly related, but
still confidently alignable,
protein sequences.
And they derived new parameters.
And in the end this matrix they
came up with called BLOSUM62
seems to work well in
a variety of contexts
when comparing moderately
distantly related
proteins or quite
distantly related proteins.
If you're comparing
very similar proteins
it almost doesn't matter.
Any reasonable
matrix will probably
give you the right answer.
But when you're comparing
the more distant ones,
that's where it
becomes challenging.
And so this is the
BLOSUM62 matrix here.
And you can see it's similar
to the PAM matrices in that-- I
think we showed PAM 250
last time-- in that you have
a diagonal with all
positive numbers.
And it's also similar in
that, for example, trytophan
down here has a higher
positive score than others.
It's plus 9.
And cysteine is also
one of the higher ones.
But those are less extreme.
And basically, maybe over short
periods of evolutionary time,
you don't change your cysteine.
But over longer periods
there is some rewiring
of disulfide bonding, and
so cysteines can change.
Something like that
may be going on.
So we've just talked about
pairwise sequence alignments.
But in practice you
often have, especially
these days you often have,
many proteins though.
So you want to align three or
five or 10 different proteins
together to find
out which residues
are most conserved, for example.
And so basically
the principles are
similar to pairwise alignment.
But now you want
to find alignments
that bring the greatest
number of single characters
into register.
So if you're aligning
three proteins,
you really want to have
columns where all three are
the same residue, or
very similar residues.
And you need to then
define scoring systems,
define gap penalties,
and so forth.
This is also reasonably
well described in the text.
I just wanted to
make one comment
about the sort of computational
complexity of multiple sequence
alignment.
So if you think about
pairwise sequence alignment,
say with Needleman-Wunsch
or Smith-Waterman,
with a sequence
of length-- let's
say you're aligning one
protein of sequence length n
to another of life n, what is
the computational complexity
of that calculation in using
this big O notation that we've
talked about?
Let's just say
standard gap penalties,
linear gap penalties.
Anyone?
Or does it matter?
Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: n squared.
PROFESSOR: It's n squared.
So even though this has gaps,
with local-- with ungapped
it was also n
squared, or n times n,
So why is it that gaps
don't make it worse?
Or do they?
Any thoughts on that?
STUDENT: You put a constant
number of gaps in the sequence.
So it's just stating the
essence of the complexity
should still be n squared.
PROFESSOR: You put a
constant number of gaps?
The-- I mean, yeah-- let's just
hear a few different comments.
And then we'll try to summarize.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: So we're
still only filling out
an n by n matrix
at any given time.
PROFESSOR: You're still filling
out an n by n matrix, right.
There happen to be
a few more things.
The recursion is slightly
more complicated.
But there's a few
more things you
have to calculate
to fill in each.
But it's like three
things, or four things.
It's not-- so it doesn't
grow with the size.
So it's just still n squared,
but with a larger constant.
OK, good.
And then if you did
affine gap penalty,
remember where you
had a gap opening
penalty and a gap
extension, what then?
Does that make it worse?
Or is it still n squared?
STUDENT: I think
it's still n squared.
PROFESSOR: Why is that?
STUDENT: Computing the affine
gap penalty is no more than o
of n, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
basically with the affine
you have to keep track of
two things at each place.
So yeah, it is.
You're right.
It's still n squared.
It's just you got to keep track
of two numbers in each place
there.
OK, good.
And so what about when
we go to three proteins?
So how would you
generalize, let's say,
the Needleman-Wunsch algorithm
to align three proteins?
Any ideas?
What structure would
you use, or what--
analogous to a matrix--
yeah, in the back.
STUDENT: Another way to do
this would be have a 3D matrix.
PROFESSOR: OK, a 3D
matrix, like a cube.
And can everyone visualize that?
So yeah, basically
you could have
a version of Needleman-Wunsch
that was on a cube.
And it started in
the 0, 0, 0 corner
and went down to the n, n,
n corner, filling in in 3D.
OK so what kind of
computational complexity
do you think that
algorithm would have?
STUDENT: n cubed?
PROFESSOR: n cubed.
Yeah, makes sense.
There would be a similar
number, a few operations
to fill in each
element in the cube.
And there's n cubed.
So the way that the problem
grows with n is as n cubed.
And what about in general,
if you have k sequences?
STUDENT: n to the k?
PROFESSOR: n to the k.
So is this practical?
With three proteins and modern
computers you could do it.
You could implement
Needleman-Wunsch on a cube.
But what about with 20 proteins?
Is that practical?
So it's really not.
So if proteins are 500
residues long and there's
500 to the 20th, right.
It starts to explode.
So that approach
really only works
in two dimensions and a little
bit in three dimensions.
And it becomes impractical.
So you need to use a
variety of shortcuts.
And so this is, again,
described pretty well
in chapter six of the text.
And a commonly used-- if
you're looking for a default
multiple sequence aligner,
CLUSTALW is a common one.
There's a web
interface if you just
need to do one or
two alignments.
That works fine.
You can also download a
version called CLUSTALX
and run it locally.
And it does a lot of things
with pairwise alignments
and then combining the
pairwise alignments.
It aligns the two
closest things first
and then brings in the
next closest, and so forth.
And it does a lot of
tricks that are-- they're
basically heuristics.
They're things
that usually work,
give you a reasonable
answer, but don't necessarily
guarantee that you will find the
optimal alignment if you were
to do it on a 20 dimensional
cube, for example.
So they work reasonably
well in practice.
And then there's a variety
of other algorithms.
OK, good.
So that's a review of what
we've mostly been talking about.
And now I want to introduce
a couple of new topics.
So we're going to briefly
talk a little bit more
about Markov models
of sequence evolution.
And these are closely related
to some classic evolutionary
theory from
Jukes-Cantor and Kimura.
So we'll just
briefly mention that.
And we'll talk a little
bit about different types
of selection that sequences can
undergo-- so neutral, negative,
and positive-- and how
you might distinguish
among those for protein
coding sequences.
And this will basically
serve as an intro
into the main topic today,
which is comparative genomics.
And comparative genomics-- it's
not really a field, exactly.
It's more of an approach.
But I wanted to give you
some actual concrete examples
of computational biology
research, successful research
that has led to various types of
insights into gene regulation,
in this case,
mostly to emphasize
that computational biology
is not just a bag of tools.
We've mostly been
talking about tools.
We introduced tools
for local alignment
and multiple alignment and
statistics and so forth.
But really it's a
living, breathing field
with active research.
And even using--
comparative genomics
is one of my favorite
areas within this field.
Because it's very powerful.
And you can often use
very simple ideas.
And simple algorithms
can sometimes
give you a really interesting
biological result,
if you have the right
sequences and ask the question
the right way.
So I have posted a dozen of my
favorite comparative genomics
papers in a special
section on the website.
Obviously I'm not asking
you to read all of these.
But I'm going to give you a few
insights and approaches that
were used in each of
these papers here,
just to give you a flavor
of some of the things
that you can do with
comparative genomics,
in the hopes that this might
inspire some of your projects.
So hopefully you're
going to start
thinking about finding teammates
and thinking about projects.
And this will hopefully
help in that direction.
Of course, they don't have to be
comparative genomics projects.
You could do anything
in computational biology
or systems biology
in this class.
But that's just one area
to start thinking about.
Yeah, I'll also--
I'm sorry, I think
I haven't posted this yet.
But I will also post
this review by Sabeti
that has a good discussion of
positive selection a little bit
later.
Again, not required.
All right, so let's go
back to this question
that I posed earlier.
We have a Markov model of
DNA sequence evolution.
And we-- sn is the
base at generation n.
And then what happens
after a long time?
If you take any vector--
q, to start with,
might be a known
base, for example--
and apply that
matrix many times,
what happens as n
goes to infinity.
And so it turns out that
there's fairly classical theory
here that gives us an answer.
This is not all the
theory that exists,
but this describes
the typical case.
So the theory says that if all
of the elements in the matrix
are greater than 0,
and then of course
all of the-- pij's, when you sum
over j, they have to equal 1.
That's just for it to be a
well-defined Markov chain.
Because you're
going from i to j.
And so from any base
you have to go--
the probability of going
to one of those four bases
has to sum to 1.
And so if those conditions
hold, then there
is a unique vector r such
that r equals r times p.
And the limit of
q times p to the n
equals r, independent
of what q was.
So basically, wherever
you were starting
from-- you could
have been starting
from 100% g, or 50%
a, 50% g, or 100%
c-- you apply this
matrix many, many times,
you will eventually
approach this vector r.
And the theory doesn't
say what r is, exactly.
But it says that r
equals r times p.
And that turns out to basically
implicitly define what r is.
That is, you can solve
for r using that equation.
And r, for this reason, because
the matrix doesn't move r,
r is called the
stationary distribution.
And it's often also called
the limiting distribution,
for obvious reasons.
And if you want to read more,
like where this theory comes
from, here's a
reasonable reference.
So any questions
about this theory?
All the elements
in the matrix have
to be strictly greater
than 1-- I'm sorry,
strictly greater than 0.
Otherwise, really no conditions.
All right, question?
Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: Does the [INAUDIBLE]
distribution ever change,
based on the sequence, or are
we assuming that it doesn't?
PROFESSOR: The theory
says it only depends on p.
It doesn't depend on q.
So it depends on the model
of how the changes happen,
the conditional probability
of what the base will
be at the next
generation given what
it is at the current generation.
It doesn't depend
where you start.
q is what your
starting point is,
what base you're initially at.
Does that make sense?
And this is obviously
a very simplified case,
where we're just modeling
evolution of one base,
and we're not thinking
about whether the rates vary
at different positions
or within-- this
is the simplest case.
But it's important to
understand the simplest case
before you start
to generalize that.
OK, so let's do
some examples here.
So here are some matrices.
So it turns out the math is
a lot easier if you limit
yourself to a two-letter
alphabet instead of four.
So that's what I've done here.
So let's look at these matrices
and think about what they mean.
So we have two-letter alphabet.
R is purine.
Y is pyrimidine.
These matrices describe
the conditional probability
that, at the next generation,
you'll be, for example-- oops,
here we go.
That, for example, if
you start at purine,
that you'll remain purine
at the next generation.
That would be 1 minus P. And
the probability that you'll
change to pyrimidine is P. And
the probability of pyrimidine
will remain as a
pyrimidine is 1 minus P.
So what is the stationary
distribution of this matrix?
OK, so if p is small, this
describes a typical model,
where most of the
time you remain--
DNA replication and
repair is faithful.
You maintain the same base.
But occasionally a mutation
happens with probability p.
Anyone want to guess what the
stationary distribution is
or describe a strategy
for finding it?
Like what do we know
about this distribution?
Or imagine you
start with a purine
and then you apply
this matrix many times
to that vector that's 1
comma 0, what will happen?
Yeah, Levi.
STUDENT: Probably 50-50 because
any other that way you skew it
it would be pushed
towards the center
because there's more
[INAUDIBLE] the other.
PROFESSOR: OK,
everyone get that?
So Levi's comment was
that it's probably 50-50.
Because mutation
probabilities are symmetrical.
Purine-pyrimidine and
pyrimidine-purine are the same.
So if you were to start
with say, lots of purine,
then there will be more
mutation toward pyrimidine
in a given generation.
So if you think about this
is your population of R
and that's your population
of Y, then if this is bigger
than that, you'll tend
to push it more that way.
And there will be less
mutation coming this way,
until they're equal.
And then you'll have equal
flux going both directions.
So that's a good way
to think about it.
And that's correct.
Can you think of how
would you show that?
What's a way of solving for
the stationary distribution?
Anyone?
So remember, we'll
just get back one.
The theory says
that R equals RP.
That's the key.
R equals RP.
So what is R?
Well we don't know R. So we
let that be a general vector.
So notice there's only
one free parameter.
Because the two components
have to sum to 1.
It's a frequency vector,
so x and 1 minus x.
And we just multiply
this times the matrix.
So you take x comma 1 minus x.
And you multiply
it by this matrix.
The matrix is 1 minus P P.
I'm using too much space here.
I'll just make it a little
smaller-- P 1 minus P.
And that's going
to equal R. And so
we'll get x times 1
minus P plus-- remember,
it's dot product of this
times this column, right?
So x times 1 minus P
plus 1 minus x times P.
That's the first component.
And the second
component will be xp
plus 1 minus x times 1 minus p.
OK, everyone got that?
So now what do we do?
STUDENT: r.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
STUDENT: Make that
equal to the initial r.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, make that
So it's two equations
and-- well, you really
only need one equation here.
Because we've already
simplified it.
In general there will
be two equations.
There will be one
equation that says
that the components of
the vector sum to 1.
And there will be another
equation coming from here.
But we can just use
either one, either term.
So we know that
the first component
of a vector-- if this vector
is equal to that vector, then
the first components
have to be equal, right?
So x equals x
times-- times what?
Times 1 minus p, just
combining these two.
And then plus what are all the--
I'm sorry, that's 1 minus p-- 1
minus p here.
And then there's another
term here, minus another p.
And then there's a
term that's just p.
And so then what do you do?
You just solve for x.
And I think when
you work this out
you'll get two p x equals
p, so x equals 1/2.
Right, everyone got that?
OK, so yeah.
So if x is 1/2, then the
vector is 1/2 comma 1/2,
which is the unbiased.
All right, what about
this next matrix,
right below-- 1
minus p 1 minus q.
p and q are two positive
numbers that are different.
So now there's actually
a different probability
of mutating purine to pyrimidine
and pyrimidine to purine.
So Levi, can we
apply your approach
to see what the answer is?
STUDENT: Not exactly.
PROFESSOR: Not exactly?
OK, yeah, it's not as obvious.
It's not symmetrical anymore.
But can anyone guess
what the answer might be?
Yeah, go ahead Diego.
STUDENT: It'll go either
all the way to one side
or depending on q and d.
PROFESSOR: All the way to
one side or all the way
to the other?
So meaning it'll be all purine
or all pyrimidine again.
STUDENT: Yeah,
depending on which--
PROFESSOR: Which is bigger?
OK, anyone else have
an alternative theory?
Yeah, go ahead.
What was your name again?
STUDENT: Daniel.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, Daniel?
STUDENT: Daniel, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Daniel.
OK, go ahead.
STUDENT: It'll reach some
intermediate equilibrium
once they balance
each other out.
And that would be exactly--
I'm not sure-- some ratio of q
to p.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How many people think
that might happen?
OK, some people.
OK Daniel has maybe
slightly more supporters.
So let's see.
So how are we going
to solve this?
How do we figure out what the
stationary distribution is?
You just use that same approach.
So you can do-- you
have x 1 minus x
times that matrix, which is got
the 1 minus p p q 1 minus q.
OK, and so now you'll
get x 1 minus p.
Anyway, go through
the same operations.
Solve for x.
And you will get-- I think I put
the answer on the slide here.
You will get q over p plus q.
So as Danny predicted, some
ratio involving q's and p's.
And does this make sense?
Seeing what the
answer is, can you
rationalize why that's true?
STUDENT: It's like a
kind of equilibrium.
You have one mode of
force play pushing
one way and another
different one
in this case pushing the other.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
basically the same idea.
And so they have
to be in balance.
So the one that has less, where
the mutation rate is a lower,
will end up being bigger, so
that the amount that flows out
will be the same as the
amount that flows in.
You can apply Levi's
idea of thinking
about how much flux
is going in each way.
So there's going to be some
flux p in one direction, q
in the other direction.
And you want x times p to
equal 1 minus x times q.
And this is the
value of that works.
OK, good?
What about this guy down here?
So this is a very special matrix
called the identity matrix.
And what kind of model
of evolution is this?
STUDENT: There's no mutation.
PROFESSOR: There's no evolution.
This is like a perfect
replication repair system.
The base never changes.
So what's a stationary
distribution?
STUDENT: It's all--
PROFESSOR: What's that?
STUDENT: It'll just
stay where it is.
PROFESSOR: It'll
That's right.
So any vector is
stationary for this matrix.
Remember that the
theory said there's
a unique stationary
distribution.
This seems to be inconsistent.
Why is it not inconsistent?
Sally?
STUDENT: We defined all of the
variables to be greater than 0.
So when you have anything that's
[INAUDIBLE] that is equal to 0.
PROFESSOR: Right, so a
condition of the theorem
is that all the entries be
strictly greater than 0.
And this is why.
If you have 0s, in there
then crazy things can happen.
Wherever you start, that's where
you end up with this matrix.
So every vector is stationary.
And what about this crazy
matrix over here, matrix q?
What does it do?
Joe.
STUDENT: It's going to
swap them back and forth.
PROFESSOR: It swaps
them back and forth.
So this is like a
hyper mutable organism
that has such a high
mutation rate that it always
mutates every base
to the other kind.
It's never happy
with its genome.
It always wants to switch
it, get something better.
And so what can you say about
the stationary distribution
for this matrix?
Jeff?
STUDENT: There isn't
going to be one.
PROFESSOR: There
isn't going to be one?
Anyone else?
STUDENT: Well, actually, I
guess 1, 1, like 0.5, 0.5.
PROFESSOR: 0.5, 0.5
would be stationary.
Because you're--
STUDENT: But you
won't converge to it.
PROFESSOR: But you
That's right. it's
stationary, but not limiting.
And again, the
theory doesn't apply.
Because there's some
0s in this matrix.
But you can still
think about that.
OK, everyone got that?
All right, good.
OK so let's talk now
about Jukes-Cantor.
So Jukes-Cantor is very
much a Markov model
of DNA sequence evolution.
And it simply has-- now
we've got four bases.
It's got probability alpha
of mutating from each base
to any other base.
And so the overall mutation
rate, or probability
of substitution, at one
generation is three alpha.
Because from the base G there's
an alpha probability mutate
to A, an alpha probability
to C, an alpha to T,
so the three alpha.
And you can basically
write a recursion
that describes
what's going on here.
So if you start
with a G at time 0,
the probability of a G at
time 1 is 1 minus 3 alpha.
It's a probability
that you didn't mutate.
But then, at generation
two, you have
to consider two cases really.
First of all, if you
didn't mutate, that's PG1.
Then you have a 1
minus alpha probability
of not mutating
again, so remaining G.
But you might have mutated.
With probability 1
minus PG 1 you mutated.
And then whatever
you were-- might
be a C-- you have
an alpha probably
of mutating back to G.
Does that make sense?
Everyone clear why there's a 3
in one place and only a 1 alpha
in the other?
All right, so you can
actually solve this recursion.
And you get this
expression here, P G of t
equals 1/4 plus 3/4 E
to the minus 4 alpha t.
OK so what does that
tell you about-- we
know from our
previous discussion
what the stationary distribution
of this Markov chain
is going to be.
What will it be?
What's the stationary
distribution?
STUDENT: 1/4 of each.
PROFESSOR: 1/4 of each.
And why, Daniel, is that?
STUDENT: Because the probability
of them moving to any base
is the same?
PROFESSOR: Right, it's
totally symmetrical.
So that has to be the
answer by symmetry.
And you could solve it.
You could use this same
approach with defining
a value-- the theory applies
if alpha is greater than 0
and less than 1-- or
less than-- I think
it has to be less than
a quarter, actually,
or something like that.
And you can apply the theory.
So there will be a
stationary distribution.
You can set up a vector.
Now you have to have four
terms in it and multiplication.
And then you'll get a
system of basically four
equations and four unknowns.
And you can solve that
system using linear algebra
and get the answer.
And yeah, the answer will
be 1/4, as you guessed.
And so what this
Jukes-Cantor expression
tells you is how quickly does
it get to that equilibrium.
We're thinking about G.
You can start at 100% G.
And it will then approach 1/4.
You can see 1/4
is clearly what's
going to happen in the limit.
Because as t gets big that
second term is going to 0.
And so what does the
distribution look like?
How rapidly do you approach 1/4?
You approach it exponentially.
So you start at 1 here.
And this is 0.
This is 1/4.
You'll start here.
And you'll go like that.
You go rapidly at the beginning.
And then you get just
very gradual approach 1/4.
So you can do a little bit more
algebra with this expression.
And here's where the really
useful part comes in.
And you can show
that K, which we'll
define as the true number
of substitutions that
have occurred at this particular
base that we're considering,
is related to D, where D is
the fraction of positions that
differ when you just take
say the parental sequence
and the daughter sequence,
the eventual sequence
that you get to.
You just match those two.
And you count up
the differences.
That's D. And then K
is the actual number
of substitutions
that have occurred.
And those are related by this
equation, K equals minus 3/4,
natural log, 1 minus 4/3 d.
So let's try to
think about, first
of all, what is the
shape of that curve?
What does that look like?
Here's 0.
I'll put 1 over here.
So we all know that log--
if it was just simply
log of something
between 0 and 1,
it would look like
what-- look like that.
Starts from negative infinity
and comes up to 0 at 1.
But it's actually not log
of D. It's log of 1 minus D,
or 1 minus a constant times
D. So that will flip it.
So the minus infinity
will be there.
It will come in like that.
And then we also have minus 3/4.
There's a minus in front
of this whole thing.
So all these logs are of
numbers that are less than 1.
So they're all negative.
But then it'll get flipped.
So it'll actually
look like that.
And it will go to
infinity where?
Where does this go to infinity?
So if this is now
K is on this axis.
And yeah, sorry if
that wasn't clear.
D is here.
So this is just
again, this is if we
did log of D it
would look like this.
If we do log of 1 minus
something times D,
that'll flip it.
And then if we do minus that,
it'll flip it again that way.
OK so now K, as a function of
D, is going to look like this.
Sometimes people
like to put-- anyway,
but let's just think about this.
So it's going to go to
up to infinity somewhere.
And where is that?
STUDENT: 3/4.
PROFESSOR: 3/4.
So does that make sense?
Can someone tell
us what's going on
and what is the use of
this whole thing here?
Yeah, in the back.
What's your name?
STUDENT: Julianne.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Julianne.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] 0.
So part, it would give
you negative infinite.
And so you just
solve for D in there.
PROFESSOR: OK, so when D is
3/4 you'll get 1 minus 1.
You get 0.
That'll be negative infinity.
And then there's
a minus in front,
so it'll be constant infinity.
So that's true.
And does that intuitively
make sense to you?
We have a sequence.
It's evolving randomly,
according to this model.
And then we have that
ancestral sequence.
And then we have a modern
descendant of that sequence,
millions of generations-- or
maybe thousands of generations,
or some large number
of generations away.
We line up those two sequences.
We count how many matches
and how many mismatches.
What's the fraction
of mismatches,
of differences we have?
Basically if that-- let's
look at a different case.
What if d is very small?
What if it's like 1%.
Then what happens?
If d is small, turns out
k is pretty much like d.
It grows linearly with
d in the beginning.
So does that make sense?
That makes sense.
Because k is the true number
of substitutions that happen.
When you go one
generation, the true number
of substitutions and
the measured number
of substitutions is the same.
Because there's
no back mutations.
But when you go further,
there's an increasing chance
of a back-- there's
an increasing chance
of a mutation, therefore
increasing chance
that you also have
a back mutation.
And so this is what
happens at long time.
So basically this is linear
here and then goes up like that.
And so what this
allows you to do
is d something that
you can measure.
And then k is something
that you want to know.
The point is, if I measure
the difference between human
and chimp sequence, it
might be only 1% different.
And if I have an idea of
mutation rate per generation,
I configure out how
many generations apart,
or how much time has passed,
since humans split from chimp.
But if I go to mouse, where the
average base might be-- there
might be only a 50%
matching-- if that's true,
there have been a
lot of changes there.
There will be a lot of bases
that have changed once,
as well as a lot that
may have changed twice,
and may have actually
changed back.
And so that let's say human
and mouse are 50% identical.
That 50% identical--
I can't just
compare it to let's
say the 1% with chimp
and say it's 50 times longer.
That 50% will be
an underestimate
of the true difference.
Because there's been some
back mutations as well.
And so you have to
use this formula
to figure out what the
true evolutionary time is,
the true number of
changes that happened.
Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: Does simple count
refer to just the difference
in the amount of mutations?
Or what's--
PROFESSOR: The simple count
is what you actually observe.
So you have a
stretch of sequence--
let's say the beta globin
genomic locus in human.
You line it up to the beta
globin locus in chimp.
You count what fraction
of positions differ?
What fractions are different?
That's d.
And then k is-- actually, it's
slightly complicated here.
Because if this is
human and that's chimp,
then k is more like--
because you don't actually
observe the ancestor.
You observe chimp.
So you have to go back to the
ancestor and then forward.
So that's the relevant
number of generations.
And so k will tell
you how many changes
must have occurred to
give you that observed
fraction of differences.
And for short
distances, it's linear.
And then for long, it's
logarithmic, basically.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: So I'm guessing all
of [INAUDIBLE] that selection
is absent.
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
This is ignoring selection.
That's a good point.
So think about this.
And let me if other
questions come up.
So this actually
came up the other day
when we were talking about
DNA substitution models.
So Kimura and
others have observed
that transitions occur much
more often than transversions,
maybe two to three
times as often,
and so proposed a
matrix like this.
And now you can
use what you know
about stationary
distributions to solve
for the limiting or stationary
distribution of this matrix.
And actually, you will find
it's still symmetrical.
It's a little bit
more complicated now,
but you'll still
get that 1/4, 1/4.
But then more
recently others have
observed that
really, dinucleotides
matter in terms
of mutation rates,
particularly in
vertebrates So what's
special about vertebrates is
that they have methylation
machinery that methylates
CPG dinucleotides on the C.
And that makes those
C's hypermutable.
They mutate at about 10 times
the rate of any other base.
And so you can give a
higher mutation rate to C,
but that doesn't
really capture it.
It's really a higher mutation
rate of C's that are next
to G's.
And so you can
define a model that's
16 by 16, which has
dinucleotide mutation rates.
And that's actually
a better model
of DNA sequence evolution.
And it's just the math
gets a little hairier
if you want to calculate
stationary distribution.
But again, it can be done.
And it's actually
pretty easy to simulate.
Knowing that it will
converge to the stationary,
you can just run the
thing many times.
And you'll get to the answer.
And there's even been
strand-specific models
proposed, where there are
some differences between how
the repair machinery treats
the two DNA strands that
are related to transcription
coupled repair.
So you actually get
some asymmetries there.
And this is a
reasonably rich area.
And you can look at some
of these references.
All right, so one more
topic, while we're on
evolution-- this
is very classical.
But I just wanted to make sure
that everyone has seen it.
If you are looking specifically
at protein coding sequences,
exons, and you know the reading
frame, you can just align them.
And then you can look
at two different types
of substitutions.
You can look at what are
called the nonsynonymous
substitutions, so changes
to the codons that change
the underlying amino acid,
the encoded amino acid.
And you define
often a term that's
either called Ka or dN,
depending who you read,
that is the fraction of
nonsynonymous substitutions
divided by nonsynonymous sites.
And in this case let's
do synonymous first.
So you can also look
at the other changes.
So these are now
synonymous changes
which are base
changes to triplets
that do not change the
encoded amino acid.
So in this case, there
are three of those.
And a lot of
evolutionary approaches
are just based on calculating
these two numbers.
You count synonymous changes.
You divide by
synonymous sites, count
non-synonymous substitutions,
divide by non-synonymous sites.
And so what do we
mean synonymous site?
Well if you have only amino
acids that are fourfold,
that have fourfold
degenerate codons,
which is all of them are
like that in this case,
then for example GG-- or
let's see what's up here.
Yeah, CC anything
codes for proline.
Do we have any of those?
Actually, these are not
all fourfold degenerate.
I apologize.
But glycine, for example--
so GG anything is glycine.
So in this triplet,
this triplet here,
there's one synonymous site.
The third side is
a synonymous site.
You can change that without
changing the amino acid.
But the other two
are non-synonymous.
So to do first
approximation, you
take non-synonymous
substitutions
and divide by the number
of codons-- I'm sorry,
the number of codons
times 2, since there
are two non-synonymous
positions in each codon.
And you take synonymous
substitutions,
divide by the number of codons.
OK, does that make sense?
One per codon.
OK and so what do you
then do with this?
You can correct this
value using-- basically
this is the
Jukes-Cantor correction
that we just calculated,
this 3/4 log 1 minus 4/3.
That applies to codon evolution
as well as individual base
evolution.
And what people
often do with this
is they calculate Ka
and Ks for a whole gene.
Let's say you have
alignments of all human genes
to their orthologs
in mouse-- that
is, the corresponding
homologous gene in mouse.
And you calculate Ka Ks.
And then you can
look at those genes
where this ratio is
significantly less than 1,
or around 1, or greater than 1.
And that actually
tells you something
about how that-- the
type of selection
that that gene is experiencing.
So what would you
expect to see--
or if I told you
we've got two genes
and the Ka/Ks ratio
is much less than 1.
It's like 0.2.
What would that tell you?
Or what could you infer
about the selection
that's happening to that gene?
Ka/Ks is much less than 1.
Any ideas?
Julianne, yeah.
STUDENT: The protein
sequence is important--
or the amino acid sequence.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
The amino acid
sequence is important.
Because you assume
that those synonymous
sites and non-synonymous
sites-- they're
going to mutate at
the same rate, right?
The mutation processes don't
know about protein coding.
So what you're seeing
is an absence, a loss,
of the non-synonymous changes.
80% of those
non-synonymous changes
have been kicked
out by evolution.
You're only seeing 20%.
And you're using, assuming
the non-synonymous are
neutral-- I'm sorry.
I seem to have trouble
with these words today.
But you assume that the
synonymous ones are neutral.
And then that's
calibrates everything.
And then you see that the
non-synonymous are much lower.
Therefore you must have
lost-- these ones must
have been kicked
out by evolution.
So the amino acid
sequence is important.
And it's optimal in some sense.
The protein works-- the organism
does not want to change it.
Or changes to that
protein sequence
make the protein worse.
And so you don't see them.
And that's what you see
for most protein coding
genes in the genome-- a Ka/Ks
ratio that's well below one.
It says we care
what the protein is.
And it's pretty good already.
And we don't want to change it.
All right, what
about a gene that
has a Ka/Ks ratio of around 1?
Anyone have an idea what would
that tell you about that gene?
There are some-- Daniel?
STUDENT: The sequence is-- it
doesn't particularly matter.
Maybe it's a non-coding,
non-regulatory patch of DNA.
I assume there
must be something.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it could
be that it's not really
protein coding after all.
It's non-coding.
Then this whole triplet thing we
were doing to it is arbitrary.
So you don't expect any
particular distribution.
That's true.
Any other possibilities?
Yeah, Tim.
STUDENT: Could be that there
are opposite forces that
are equilibrating.
For example, we're
taking the unit of the G.
But maybe in one
half of the G there's
a strong selective
pressure for non-synonymous
and in the other half it's
strong selective pressure
for synonymous.
Alternatively, it could be
in the same par of the gene,
but it's involved in
two different processes.
It's diatropic.
So in one process it's
selecting this one thing.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, or
one period of time,
if you're looking at 10
million years of evolution,
it could have been for this
first five million years it was
under negative selection, and
then it was under positive.
And it averages out.
Yes, all those things are
possible, but kind of unusual.
And so maybe if
you saw that the--
if you plotted
Ka/Ks along the gene
and you saw that it was high
in one area and low in another,
then that would tell
you that you probably
shouldn't be taking the
average across the gene.
And that would be a
good thing to look for.
But what if-- again, so
we said if Ka/Ks is near 1
it could be that it's not really
a protein coding gene at all.
That's certainly possible.
It could also be though
that it's a pseudogene.
Or it's a gene that is no
longer needed by the organism.
It still codes for protein,
but the organism just
could care less
about its function.
It's something that maybe
evolved in some other time.
It helps you adapt to
when the temperature gets
below minus 20.
But it never gets
below minus 20 anymore.
And so there's no selection
on it, or something like that.
So neutral indicates-- this
is called neutral evolution.
And then what about a gene which
has a Ka/Ks ratio significantly
greater than 1?
Any thoughts on what that might
mean and what kind of genes
might happen to--
yes, what's your name?
STUDENT: Simona.
PROFESSOR: Simona, go ahead.
STUDENT: It might be a gene
that's selected against,
so something that's detrimental
to the cell or the organism.
PROFESSOR: It's detrimental--
so the existing protein is
bad for you, so you
want to change it.
So it's better to change
it to something else.
That's true.
Can you think of an example
where that might be the case?
STUDENT: A gene that
produces a toxin.
PROFESSOR: A gene
that produces toxin.
You might just lose
the gene completely
if it produced a toxin.
Any other examples you can
think of or other people?
Yeah, Jeff.
STUDENT: Maybe a
pigment that makes
the organism more susceptible
to being eaten by a predator.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah if
it was a polar organism
and it happened to have this
gene that made the fur dark
and it showed up against the
snow, or something like that.
And you can imagine that.
Or a very common
case is, for example,
a receptor that's used by
a virus to enter the cell.
It probably had
some other purpose.
But if the virus
is very virulent,
you really just want
to change that receptor
so that the virus can't
attack it anymore.
So you see this kind
of thing is much rarer.
It's only less than
1% of genes probably
are under positive selection,
depending on how you measure it
and what time
period you look at.
But it tends to be really
recent, really strong selection
for changing the
protein sequence.
And the most common-- well,
probably the most common--
is these immune arms races
between a host and a pathogen.
But there are other cases too.
You can have very
strong selection
where-- well, I don't
want to-- basically where
a protein is maladapted, like
the organism moves from a very
cold environment to a
very warm environment.
And you just need to
change a lot of stuff
to make those proteins
better adapted.
Occasionally you can get
positive selection there.
Yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: So the situation
where K or Ks is 1--
could it be possible that
the mRNA is under selection?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so that
basically we have always
been implicitly assuming that
the synonymous substitution
rate was neutral.
But it could actually
be it's not neutral.
That's under negative
selection too.
And it happens
that they balance.
That's also possible.
So for that, to
assess that, you might
want to compare the synonymous
substitution rate of that gene
to neighboring genes.
And if you find it's
much lower, that
could indicate that
the coding sequences--
the third base of codons
is under selection--
could be for splicing, maybe.
It could be for RNA secondary
structure, translation,
different other--
that's a good point.
So yeah, you guys have
already poked holes in this.
This is a method.
It gives you something.
You'll see it used.
It gives you some inferences.
But there are cases where
it doesn't fully work.
OK, good.
So in the remaining
time I wanted
to do some examples of
comparative genomics.
So as I mentioned
before, these are
chosen to just give you some
examples of types of things
you can learn about
gene regulation
by comparing genomes again,
often by using really
simple methods,
just blasting all
the genes against each
other or things like this.
And also, if you do choose
to read some of these papers,
it can give you some
experience looking
at this literature in
regulatory genomics.
So the papers I've chosen--
we'll start with Bejerano et al
from 2002, who basically sought
to identify regulatory elements
that are things that are
under evolutionary constraint.
That's all he was
trying to find.
Didn't know what
their functions were.
But they turned out to be
interesting nonetheless,
which is maybe a
little surprising.
And then this other work from
Eddy Rubin's lab and others--
Steve Brenner's lab--
actually characterized
some of these extremely
conserved regions
and assessed their function.
And then Bejerano came
back a few years later
and actually had a paper about
where these extremely conserved
regions actually came from.
So we'll talk about those.
Then we'll look at
some papers that
have to do with inferring
the regulatory targets
of a transacting factor.
And the factors that
we'll consider here
will be microRNAs,
mostly, Either trying
to understand what the
rules are for microRNA
targeting and these
Lewis et al papers,
or trying to identify
the regulatory targets
in the genome.
And then, time permitting, we'll
talk about a few other examples
of slightly more exotic things.
Graveley identified
a pair-- or pairs--
of interacting
regulatory elements
through a clever comparative
genomic approach.
And then I'll talk about
these two examples at the end
if there's time, where a new
class of transacting factors
was inferred from the
locations of the encoded genes
in the genome.
And also an inference was
made about the functions
of some repetitive
elements from, again,
looking at the matching
between these elements
and another genome.
All right, so first
example-- Bejerano
"Ultraconserved elements."
So they defined, in a fairly
arbitrary way, ultraconserved
elements as unusually
long segments
that 100% identical between
human, mouse, and rat.
This was in 2000--
I'm sorry, I might
have the wrong-- it's
either 2004 or 2002.
I forget.
This was basically when the
first three mammalian genomes
had been sequenced, which
were human, mouse, and rat.
And there were whole
genome alignments.
So they basically said let's
try to use these whole genome
alignments to find
what's the most
conserved thing in mammals.
So they wanted to see if
there's anything 100% conserved.
And so they did
statistics to say
what's an unusually long
region of 100% identity.
Any ideas how you would do
that calculation, what kind
of statistics you would use?
They used a really
simple approach.
What they did was they
took one megabase segments
of the genome, assuming it
might vary across the genome.
They took ancestral repetitive
elements-- so repetitive
elements that were
inserted, that
were present in mouse,
rat, and human--
and assumed that they
were neutrally evolving,
they were not under selection.
And then therefor you could look
at the number of differences
and get an idea what the
background rate of mutation is.
And they use that.
And they found that
that rate was--
this is from their supplementary
data-- that was never greater
than 0.68.
And so they just said well, if
we have a probability of-- I'm
sorry.
One is heads.
So if they're all
three the same-- yeah,
so if we have a probability
of 0.7 of heads,
meaning that they're
all three the same,
then the chance that you
have 200 heads in a row
would be 1 minus P P to the 200,
just like [INAUDIBLE] trials.
And you can just multiply that
times the size of the genome.
And you say it's extremely
unlikely that you'll ever
see anything where there's 200
identical nucleotides in a row.
So that's what they defined
as an ultraconserved element.
So it all seems
very silly for now,
until you actually
get to what they find.
So they looked at where
are these elements
around the genome.
They found about 100 overlapped
exons of known protein coding
genes, 100 are in
introns, and the remainder
are in intergenic regions.
So then they looked at
well what kind of genes
contain exons with
overlapping-- or contain
ultraconserved elements
that overlap exons?
Those are type 1 genes.
And what kind of
genes are next to
the intergenic
ultraconserved elements,
to try to get some clues about
the function of these elements.
And so they did this early
gene ontology analysis.
And what they found was that
the ultraconserved elements that
overlapped exons
tended to fall in genes
that encoded RNA-binding
proteins, particular splicing
factors, by an order of
magnitude more frequent.
And then the type 2
genes, the ones that
were next to these intergenic
ultraconserved regions,
tended to be
transcription factors.
In particular, homeobox
transcription factors
were the most enriched class.
So this gave them some clues
about what might be going on.
Particularly the second
class was followed up
by Eddy Rubins's
lab at Berkeley.
And they tested 167 extremely
conserved sequences.
So some of them were these
ultraconserved elements.
And some of them were
just highly conserved,
but not quite 100% conserved.
And they had an assay
where they have a reporter.
It's a lacZ with a-- you
take a minimal promoter, fuse
in to lacZ, and then
you take your element
of interest and
fuse it upstream.
And then you do staining
of whole mount embryos.
And you say what pattern
of gene expression
does this element
drive, or does it
drive a pattern of
gene expression?
And so 45% of the time it
drove a particular pattern
of gene expression.
So it functioned as an enhancer.
And these are the types
of patterns that they saw.
So they saw often
forebrain, sometimes
midbrain, neural
tube, lim, et cetera.
So many of these
things are enhancers
that drive particular
developmental patterns of gene
expression.
So that out to be actually--
that was a pretty good way
to identify
developmental enhancers.
So they wondered, is
there anything special
about these ultraconserved
regions, these 100%
identical regions, versus
others that are 95% identical.
And so they tested
a bunch of each.
And they found absolutely
no difference there.
They drive similar
types of expression.
And you can even find
individual instances of them
that drive pretty much exactly
the same pattern of expression.
So this whole 100%
identical thing
was just a purely-- it
was purely arbitrary.
But still, it's useful.
These things are among the
most interesting enhancers
that have been identified.
So what about the-- oh yeah,
so where did they come from?
OK, so this is totally
from left field.
Bejerano was looking at some of
these ultraconserved elements,
probably just blasting them
against different genomes
as they came out, and noticed
something very, very strange.
And that was there
had recently been
some sequencing from coelacanth.
So for those of you who
aren't fish experts,
this is a lobed fin fish,
where they found fossils
from dating back to
400 million years.
And they noticed that these
fossils-- the morphology never
changed.
From 400 million, 300 million
years, you could see this fish.
It was exactly like this.
And it has lobed fins.
That was why they're
interested in it.
Because the fins-- they
have a round structure.
They look almost like
limbs, like maybe this guy
could have evolved into
something that would eventually
live on land.
Anyway, but they
thought it was extinct.
And then somebody caught one.
In the '70s, in the West Indian
Ocean, from deep water fishing,
they pulled one up,
and it looked exactly
like these fossils from
400 million years before.
And so then of course
somebody took some DNA
and did some sequencing.
And what Bejerano noticed is
that this one megabase or so
coelacanth sequence had a
very common repeat in it that
was around 500 bases or so,
that looked like a SINE element.
SINE elements-- short,
interspersed nuclear element,
like Alus, if you're
familiar with those, so
some sort of repetitive element.
And this repetitive
element was very
similar to these ultraconserved
enhancers in mammals.
So something that
we normally think
of as the least
conserved of all,
like a repetitive element
that inserts itself randomly
in the genome, had become--
some of these elements
had become among the
most conserved sequences
later in evolution.
So how does that make
any sense at all?
Anyone have a theory on that?
I can tell you how
they interpreted it.
So their theory-- here's some
text from their-- anyway,
you can look at the paper
for the details here.
But their theory is basically
that once you have a repetitive
element-- initially it's
a parasitic element,
inserts itself
randomly in the genome,
doesn't actually do anything.
But once you have hundreds
of them, by chance
there will be perhaps
a set of genes
that have this
element next to them,
where you'd like to
control them coordinately.
You'd like to turn all those
genes on or all those genes off
in a particular circumstance--
a stress response,
during development,
something like that.
And so then it's relatively
easy to evolve a transcription
factor, for example,
that will bind
to some sequence
in that element.
And then it'll turn
on all those genes.
Of course, it'll turn
out all the genes
that have the
elements near them.
So it'll probably turn
on some extra genes
that you don't want.
But you can then-- selection
will then tune these elements.
It gives you a quick way of
generating a large-scale gene
expression response.
Because you've got so many
of these things scattered
across the genome.
And so this-- that's as good
as an explanation as we have,
I would say, for what
is going on here.
And there's been some
theories about this.
And they point out
that actually something
like 50% of our genome actually
comes from transposons,
if you go back far enough.
Some are recent,
some are ancient.
And that maybe a lot of the
regulatory elements-- not just
these ultraconserved
enhancers, but others--
may have evolved in this way.
So basically you insert a bunch
of random junk throughout.
And then the fact that
it's all identical,
because it derived
from a common source,
you use-- that fact
actually turns it
into something that's useful,
a useful regulatory element.
All right, just wanted
to throw that out.
So what about the exonic
ultraconserved elements?
So here's one.
This is a 600 18
nucleotide region
that's 10% identical between
human, mouse, and rat.
It's one of the
longest in the genome.
And where is it?
It's in a splicing
factor gene called SRp20.
And it's actually not in
the protein coding part.
It's in a essentially non-coding
exon of this splicing factor.
So it's this yellow exon here.
And what you'll notice is
there's this little red thing
here.
That's a stop codon.
So this gene is
spliced-- produces
two different isoforms.
The full length is the
blue, when you just
use all the blue exons.
But when you include
this yellow exon,
there's a premature
termination codon that you hit.
So you don't make
full-length protein.
Instead, that mRNA is
degraded in a pathway called
nonsense mediated mRNA decay.
So the purpose of
this exon appears
to be so that this gene
can regulate expression
of the protein at the
level of splicing.
And others have shown that this
protein, the protein product,
actually binds to
that exon and promotes
the splicing of that exon.
So it's basically a form of
negative auto regulation.
The gene-- when the
protein gets high,
it comes back and shifts the
splicing of its own transcripts
to produce a non-functional
form of the message
and reduce the
protein expression.
So the theory is that this
helps to keep this splicing
factor at a constant
level throughout time
and between different
cells, which
might be important for splicing.
But that's only a theory.
It could be something else.
And it does not explain why you
need 600 nucleotides perfectly
conserved in order to
have this function.
So I think these exonic
ones are still fairly
mysterious and
worth investigating.
A couple examples
from microRNAs--
you probably it's just a
brief review on microRNAs.
They are these small,
non-coding RNAs,
typically 20 to 22
nucleotides or so.
They have a characteristic
RNA secondary structure
in their precursor,
often called miRNAs.
And they're produced from
primary transcripts typically,
or introns, or
protein coding genes,
which are then processed in
the nucleus of an enzyme called
drosha into a hairpin
structure, like so.
And then that is exported
to the cytoplasm,
where it's further processed
by an enzyme called dicer
to produce the mature microRNA,
which enters the risk complex,
and which then pairs the
microRNA with mRNA targets,
usually in the 3'-UTR.
And that either inhibits
their translation
or triggers the decay
of those messages.
So microRNAs can do-- they
can be really important.
Weird animation--
but for example,
this bantam microRNA in flies
inhibits a proapoptotic gene
hid.
If you delete bantam,
apoptosis goes crazy.
And you can see this
is a normal fly.
There's a little fly in there
with red eyes and so forth.
In this guy there's
just a sack of mush.
All the cells-- most of
the cells actually died.
So microRNAs play
important roles
in developmental pathways.
And so we wanted to figure out
the rules for their targeting.
And so this was an early
study from Ben Lewis,
where he looked for conserved
instances of segments,
short oligonucleotides,
that match perfectly
to different parts
of the microRNA,
using again these human,
mouse, rat alignments,
which were what was
available at the time.
And what he found was that if
you took the set of microRNAs
which were known, and you
identified targets of these
defined as 7-mers that
are perfectly conserved
in 3'-UTRs of
mammalian messages,
and then you looked at how many
you got and you compared that
to the number of targets
of shuffled microRNA--
so where you take the
whole set of microRNAs,
randomly permute their sequences
so you generate random stuff,
look at how many conserve
targets they have--
that there was a significant
signal above background,
in the sense of real
conserved targets,
specifically only for the
5'-end of the microRNA.
Especially, bases 2 to 8 of
the microRNA gave a signal.
And no other positions
in the microRNA
gave a significant
signal above background.
And so that led to the inference
that the 5'-end of the microRNA
is what matters,
specifically these bases.
And then later,
alignments of actually
paralogous microRNA
genes, shown here--
so these are
different let-7 genes.
You can actually see that
the 5'-end of the microRNA,
which the microRNA's
shown here in blue--
this is the fold-back.
So you get conservation of the
microRNA and of the other arm
of the fold-back,
which is complimentary.
Little conservation of the loop,
but the most conserved part
of the microRNA is the very
5'-end, consistent with that
idea.
Just one more example,
because it's so cool--
so this is the dscam
gene in drosophila.
And this gene has four different
alternative spliced regions
which are each spliced by
mutually exclusive splicing.
So there are actually
12 copies of exon 4
and 48 different
copies of exon 6.
And messages from this
gene only ever contain
one of those particular exons.
And so Brent Graveley asked
how does this gene get spliced
in a mutually exclusive way?
How do you only choose one of
those 48 different versions
of exon 6?
And so what he did was did some
sequencing from various fly
and other insect species of
this locus, did some alignments.
And he noticed that there was
this very conserved sequence
just stream of exon 5, right
upstream of this cluster.
And then, looking
more carefully,
he saw that there is another
sequence, just immediately
upstream of each of
the alternative exons,
that was very similar
between all those exons,
and also conserved
across the insects.
And then he started
at these for a while,
and recognized that
actually this sequence up
at the 5'-end is-- its consensus
is perfectly complimentary
to the sequence that's found
upstream of all of the other
exons.
And so what that
suggested, immediately,
is that splicing
requires the pairing
of this sequence
from exon 5 to one
of those downstream sequences.
And then you'll splice
to the next exons that's
immediately downstream and
skip out all of the others.
And that's been
subsequently confirmed,
that that's the mechanism.
So this just shows you
that to figure this out
by molecular genetics would
have been extremely difficult.
But sometimes
comparative genomics,
when you ask the right question,
you get a really clear--
you can actually get mechanistic
insights from sequences.
So that's it.
And I'm actually passing
the baton over to David,
who will be-- take
over next week.